before the show tonight Andy asked me if
I'd give him just a couple of minutes to
get something off his chest sure go
ahead Andy Thank You Conan you know last
night's Super Bowl was some of the most
memorable in history both teams played
well and the commercials were
entertaining to boot it would have been
perfect except for one thing those
commercials for avocados bring the
camera in Billy goodnight now give me
some of that hate light you know there
we go
listen avocados I am sick of your
[ __ ] you spend millions on Superbowl
ads for what your avocados people who
like avocados like you and people who
can't stand avocados aren't gonna change
their mind you're not converting anyone
so stop advertising okay Eddie it feels
like you're overreacting just a little
pushing culture Billy come on I don't
give me this we're just raising
awareness about avocados crap we're
aware of you rock Amole avocado burgers
avocado toast vegan BLTs we can't escape
you
any-any why do you even care because
it's wasteful isn't that right avocados
you've got no competition it's not coke
versus Pepsi there's nothing else on the
planet like an avocado can anybody name
another fruit made of green mashed
potatoes with a brown golf ball in case
that an alligator sports game
[Applause]
you've got the whole field stop
advertising Thank You Carla
okay all right all right Andy by the way
in your anti avocado rant I don't know
if you realized this you said avocados
ten times 11 times going Andy Richter
for avocados avocados you can't escape
it why did you sniff it nothing avocado
we yeah
you